TIED FOR THIRD IN THE LEAGUE IN.
AGAINST THE
HAWKS.
THE LOAN WIN HERE CAME OVER TWO
HIS 29th BIRTHDAY, HE HAD A
>> Shane: 29.
DRIVING, HE GOES UPSTAIRS PAST
THE HAWKS HAD THEIR FIRST,
ALING
CHICAGO END.
THE GOLDEN
CENTER IT.GOOD CHANCE FOR THE
BLOCK
THAT N
2013 STANLEY CUPS.
DADONOV HAS IT BACK ON THE
SHORT  SIDE OF THE NET.WITH BACY
DEALS THEY SIGNED WITH THE
HAWKS EIGHT YEARS AGO.
HE WILL BREAK WITH JANMARK
SHOT AND THE SAVE  BY FLEURY.
NICE ONE FROM STONE TO
CARPENTER MOVES IT OUT UP AHEAD.
THE SHOT R THE BLOCK OR.
HE WILL PICK UP HIS THIRD OF
THE SEASON  AND .IT BACK POKED
JUST COULD NOT HANDLE THE E
THE SCORE!
I AM NOT SURE IF JONATHAN TOEWS
GOT ANOTHER TOUCH OUTFRONT.
IT DOES NOT LOOK LIKEKETO CHANG
WITH GAMES BEING POSTPONED
THROUGHOUTSOMETHING TO TAKE IN.
JUJHAR KHAIRA AND THEN  RILEY I
CONNOLLY LOSES HIS STICK,
MARK STONE, FEEDS IT ACROSS,  T
SAVE AS DADONO